so I guess we can get started hi
everyone thanks for thanks for coming
and spending
and talking podcast I see a lot of
familiar faces so thanks so for those
who don't know me my name is Amy I work
at the Yale School of Management I'm
director of digital I wear a lot of hats
within the communications department I
often I sort of describe that as sort of
part product part project social and now
sort of like a work side hustle being a
podcast producer so I'm really lucky in
that we have a broad team with lots of
talent and so we're able to kind of drop
craft as we go and so podcasting it -
something that sort of came to me
recently and I absolutely love it so so
why am i the director of digital talking
you about podcasts so and actually I'm
going to talk about my commute a little
bit I commute about two hours a day and
I've been working here for almost seven
years so I've done the math and that's
2680 eight hours of commuting which is a
lot of podcasts I can't tell you exactly
how many hours of podcasting that is but
I love podcasts I listen to them often
and a lot of us within my to know within
som have have just thought we should
really launched a podcast so you know
it's taken a couple years to go from
let's launch a podcast actually doing it
so I thought I should talk about I
should share our share our journey a
little bit and I want to stress I'm not
an expert so feel free to leave the room
I won't be offended but I'm definitely
not a podcast expert I'm just somebody
like you who loves podcasts who who
wants to promote and celebrate the great
work we do at my school and has found
that this is a great platform to do that
so I thought I would share with you our
journey for for that so but first oops
first I wanted to hear a few of the
podcasts I love and listen to it changes
all the time but I don't know it's sort
of like looking in my purse or you know
it this is if you open my podcast app
this is what you Etsy and of course
career conversations is what I'm gonna
what is what I'm here to talk about
today so I probably do not need to make
a case for podcasts because if you're
here chances are you're a fan of the
medium or want to get to know it a
little bit
better podcasting is not new it's been
around for quite a while but it is
professionalizing right now there's a
lot of listening platforms and
innovations happening within podcasting
that are pretty exciting there was a
recent or sort of recent Pew survey that
shows that podcast the podcast audience
is growing 26% of Americans have
listened to a podcast at least once a
month and they tend to be more college
educated and that's good for us at Yale
for us for those of us who create
content at Yale this seems to be a great
platform there are college-educated
folks who are probably interested in
what we're all doing and if you're if
you're interested in where podcasting is
going I actually just listened to a
really fantastic episode on the a 16 Z
podcast about where they think is going
some of the innovations that are
happening so I encourage you to check
that that episode out I've linked to it
in my presentation which I can of course
share so I'm gonna introduce you to our
podcast it's called career conversations
and if you if I find you looking at your
phone I hope you're subscribing to our
podcast right now so wherever you get
your podcasts just search for Yale
career conversations and you should find
it pretty easily and subscribe rate us
if I don't say that I would be remiss so
what is career conversations it's a
podcast series where som students sit
down with alumni for a series of candid
conversations about career paths
industries opportunities for MBAs and
discussions on various career topics
they've they really range from work/life
balance to very specific opportunities
for MBAs within a field challenges and
we also usually touch upon their
experience at som and even get some
faculty shout outs in course shout outs
as well and of course because our
mission is educating leaders for
business and society
it's also a great platform to reflect
that and so often a lot of our questions
whether they're in direct or indirect
touch upon how they are
leaders within that confluence of
business and society so we're just about
to conclude our first season of career
conversations we've had a total of seven
guests or six here because we're just
launching one next week but you'll see
where we've sort of attempted to connect
current students with alumni across
sectors as well as demographic
backgrounds so kind of stepping back I
thought I would share with you a little
bit of about how we approached career
conversations it didn't happen overnight
obviously in fact it took quite a while
but once we decided we wanted to do a
podcast it happened pretty quickly and I
think there's a spectrum of ways to
execute upon a launch of a podcast I
think we landed right in the middle we
did a lot of strategy we you know
several of us in the communication
department sat in a room we brainstormed
then we narrowed it down
we found a co-producer and we worked
through it but I would say you know the
more time you can spend at the strategy
part of your podcast launch the better
you'll be
that means you'll spend less time on the
production side which is probably also
going to mean that you're gonna spend a
lot less money so as much time as you
can spend pondering strategy and
consulting with your colleagues across
Gale there's a lot of great folks that
that can actually help you out in this
process and I'll get to that in a little
bit so so what did we think so I'll
share a little bit about how Yale how
LSO and thought about this to hopefully
help you on your own podcasting journey
so we wanted it to be a community
building exercise both in how we put the
podcast together but also how it lived
out in the world meaning as we produce
the podcast we wanted to be connecting
students and alums and faculty members
using various parts of the university
and so we really thought it would be a
community building exercise we wanted it
to sustain and deepen the bonds among
our students and alums and our fans of
the school I'll say fans because they're
maybe not necessarily within our
community but people that love som and
then we also wanted it to support our
mission for business and society that's
always the lens with
from which we create content and share
content and and of course finally if
we're doing all that really well we're
probably attracting the right folks to
the school right so prospective students
getting the right people to our programs
so sorry I'm I just uh wait so I talked
a little bit about that was a little bit
about audience right we have this kind
of internal a lot of internal and it
kind of builds out to the bull's eye of
kind of our fans and prospective
students and then we wanted to also we
wanted to also understand what the
competitive landscape looked like
there's a lot of business schools that
are doing similar things producing
similar audio formats I'd say one of the
most successful is mi t--'s data made to
matter so if you're looking to launch a
podcast I feel like you should look very
closely to what you're thinking about
but also look more broadly I think
logistically we're probably not going to
be competing with huge you know five
producer podcasts but probably more like
the HBS Michigan Ross or MIT models and
then of course what's your what's your
USP what's your hypothesis for launching
this and kind of blending that all
together and and so I think that's kind
of the final step in the strategy after
you've done these sort of goal exercises
as well as checking out your audience
and competitive analysis kind of
distilling that into your hypothesis and
so for career conversations that's when
we came up with you know we really
wanted this to be something that would
reflect our entire community and so we
put students together with alums
currently at the school talking about
different with their experiences within
each sector
so pre-production so the first step in a
podcast kind of launched or is your
strategy right that's kind of sitting in
a room whether it's an hour you can take
an hour you can bring some colleagues in
spend a few hours a few months or much
longer and then once you're done with
that strategy process what does
pre-production look like so I have to
say that I was not prepared for the
amount of time that this would take so
in fact so prepare yourself
right it's gonna take you much longer
than you think so think these are just a
few of the things you want to think
about in what I call pre-production I
get did I mention I'm not an expert so
so I learned a lot in this process but
you know you want to think about your
production schedule and really kind of
being as planning that out as much as
possible so this is kind of a glimpse at
what the production schedule looked like
for our season one and you'll see
there's you know various fields for I
mean this is pretty specific but I think
it's good to be specific right so you
have you know when we're releasing
something who the folks are that are
that are being interviewed and in our
case you know we had a book a studio we
had to schedule zoom calls we had it
sometimes we had a remote producer etc
etc so so this sort of represents kind
of the the bird's eye view and then
there's a lot of in-person prep so and
you're developing scripts and briefing
Docs so let me talk a little bit about
that so our podcast we paired a student
with an alum so the students usually on
campus the alum can be anywhere from
we've recorded interviews with folks in
San Francisco and London in New York
City and so that takes a little bit of
prep you know finding a shared time to
find a time to record would take a
little time but we like to do as much in
person prep as possible and I again this
is sort of the spend more time at the
outset so that when you're in production
you're saving yourself some time so
in-person prep is really important for
all these interviews developing scripts
and briefing Docs so this is also
something I didn't really anticipate but
which had really helped the process and
I feel like by midseason I was really
good at it I was really great at
creating a briefing doc
you're not Saddam Singh here we go so
creating briefing documents so that both
parties wherever they were in the
process would understand what was going
on you'd be shocked to know how many
folks on the day of the podcast
recording thought is this video or is
this just you know so it was still you
can never be too specific and to what
you think is obvious
so I created a briefing doc and I would
encourage you and and and wherever you
are in your podcast prep to create
briefing Docs be as specific as possible
and also you know scripts I think it's
sort of obvious stating the obvious but
I think scripts are really important
reviewing those scripts as much as
possible with your interviewer securing
audiotape sync studio time I think we'll
talk a little bit about kind of your
your quality requirements but I think
that's also really important and then
also outlook reminders I think we're all
fans are not fans about luck but we all
use it and I ended up using outlook
quite a bit to sort of be that locus for
all that information to organize for
everybody that was involved and that was
really helpful
so here's one of our students max Warren
and he was interviewing somebody who was
obviously not there and so most of our
episodes you know featured a student in
our studio at som we were lucky to have
a studio space and an alum somewhere
else so we thought most episodes would
look like this happy students seamless
press a button good to go
but that was not really always the case
sometimes I actually had to you know the
studio wasn't available the tape sync
person cancelled and I had to drag
somebody in my office run to the Apple
store to grab a microphone quickly set
up a Zen cast or feed and just record at
my desk so you know you never know
what's gonna happen with these things so
so for production I would say you know
consider ask yourself a few questions
what's your audio style what's your
tolerance for for great audio quality or
so-so audio quality you know which
probably depends on your budget and then
have you consulted an expert I think
there's some folks here that work at the
Yale broadcasting Center guys over there
and of course we have one at som and I
hear CTL also has one those are all
great resources I would encourage you to
seek out any resource that you can as a
consultant but I think also at the end
of the day consider that spectrum of
quality and maybe DIY is the way to go
right so when it comes to
post-production your post-production
checklist there's a lot of things to
consider are you gonna be editing and
mixing this yourself are you gonna hire
somebody hire somebody
what's an mp3 file verse and what's id3
tagging you should probably figure out
what those things are just mean
everything is available by Google but
again get an editor show notes I think
this is another important part of the
process when it comes to how you're
promoting and how you're offering and
kind of augmenting that content that
you're sharing transcripts are really
important you know accessibility at Yale
is really important it's something we
take into consideration all the time so
absolutely positively transcribe your
episodes when it comes to reviewing and
approving episodes obviously we want
things to be as seamless as possible and
pretty quick but I always like to give a
courtesy review to the folks that I've
interviewed or where part of the process
and then audiograms and promotion will
touch on a little bit so this is a safe
I can play this
fortunately in healthcare it's been
relatively easy for me to find meaning
in the work and being able to sit with
patients with their families really see
their lives so I just share this one
example of promotion that we found to be
successful which is an audiogram there's
free apps to do these sorts of things so
headliner app is one of the ones that
we've used so that's that's something
that we've utilized so publishing and
promoting obviously there's so many ways
in so many directions you can go with
this we tend to write a news story and
we've templatized it so I'm not I don't
have to reinvent the wheel every time we
launch an episode we've decided to
launch our end up at a new episode every
two weeks so rather than just dump them
all at once for us we thought it would
be great to kind of slowly acquire
followers and subscribers so that we can
increase our listenership and and create
more opportunities to promote it along
the way however if you already have a
great following maybe just dumping a
whole season at once is the way to go
and then promoting it thereafter so we
create news articles for each one i
embed a soundcloud listening tool within
that and we often will link out to some
other resources and show notes you'll
see me post we often post on Instagram
and Twitter and then in the case of dr.
out-con who was one of our one of our
interviewees he works at the Tufts
Medical Center so they were kind enough
to promote that and so sort of
coordinating with your subjects
obviously is is sort of a great a great
thing to always do so lessons learned
you know set aside twice the time you
think you need to do anything the whole
thing strategy twice the time production
pre-production launching it it's going
to take three times the time
3x your budget if you can create a
trailer what I learned sort of halfway
through the process of launching was
that
getting your feed set up with Apple for
example takes quite a while I could take
anywhere from three days to three weeks
it's sort of a black box so the trailer
sort of is your your test your test
episode if you will so if you're gonna
launch anything through the Apple Store
I recommend you do a lot you would do a
launch with a trailer first and it could
be a thirty second or a ten second a
little bit of audio promoting your your
podcast but then usually thereafter it's
a pretty quick a couple hours at most
and then always have a plan B or a plan
C in a plan D you know I can't as my
colleagues Emily and Jonathan know who
are here who have heard me kind of go
into your offices and say can you
believe doctor app concept you know
counsel for the third time can you
believe so you know there's so many
variables and that the though if you can
simplify your production the better off
you'll be so I think going into it I
thought you don't need a host this is
great I compare a student with an alum
this is perfect however what I didn't
anticipate was not having a host I know
you're a host right it's it's hosts are
great they're important I sort of wish I
had thought it that you know maybe we
didn't even go so not having a host
here's what happens I have to prep in
person every student when you're in the
studio with them you need to interrupt
them remind them how to say something
how to do something some of our students
don't have you know English maybe isn't
their first language and and so you have
to do many many many tapes which is fine
and I think that's important for us we
want that breath of you know
international students are important to
us it just takes a little bit more prep
right when you don't have a host so so
lesson learned
also when you're scheduling interviews
with faculty members who are very busy
with alums who are eminent in their
field these are busy folks they
certainly want to help out and engage
with you however they're probably going
to cancel on you at the last moment
sometimes with very little notice and so
what does that mean it doesn't seem like
a big deal you have a free now you have
a free hour in your schedule however
when you're a producer that means
telling the studio rebooking the studio
telling the tape sync person this
happened to be with a
person in London I had to cancel the
taping person in London I had to cancel
our on-site I also had to tell our
student and so there's this whole series
of dominoes that falls and you have to
do it in the case of doctor Afcon three
times he happens to be an amazing very
nice person so that helped however it
made it it makes it extremely stressful
I will also kind of you know I mentioned
budget triple your budget
now you can bootstrap this and I
encourage you to bootstrap it right you
know not everything has to be kind of a
very high-end production so you know get
Zen caster get a microphone from the
Apple store if you walked out of here
today
you could probably launch your first
episode in three hours if you if you
just sort of kind of again spend a
little bit of time thinking about it but
you there's enough tools and platforms
out there to do that and I would
actually encourage you to do that first
as an exercise I think that's really
important I think so many of us think we
want to launch a podcast and don't
really kind of think through the amount
of time that it will take out of your
out of your kind of workflow and it will
take a great deal of time
that's a great question and actually I
had I wasn't able to add my slide I
could probably pull it up in a quick sec
so I will actually share this with you
so I created a pseudo budget I wanted to
share with you also think about your
launch costs think about your annual
costs and think about your recurring
costs so I would say it netted out it
could net out to about a $1,500 in
episode and the reason being is if you
hire maybe somebody to get you started
and if you have a budget initial budget
I think it's really important to spend a
little bit on hiring an external
producer which we did to help get us
kick-started it gave us confidence so I
think that is really helpful you're
gonna want to think about music rights
or composing some music or you know
something like that you're gonna want to
think about sorry my slides aren't
advancing as easily as I thought they
would there we go
so you're gonna want to think about
design you know I didn't come up with
that design you know that was from a
very kind of another really fantastic
graphic designer who created that look
and feel for us but we wanted this to be
a flagship so we wanted to invest into
it right so you're gonna think about
music you're gonna think about design
you're gonna think about hosting
platforms you're gonna think about maybe
you want to do some paid marketing paid
social marketing I mean time is an
important resource if you were to
monetize that that would be a great deal
of time as well
so there's kind of a launch budget
there's a per episode budget and then
there's some annual fees so if you
decide to go with say libsyn or
blueberry I know
Yale Broadcasting said it uses blueberry
we've been using libsyn these are
platforms that if you want to
disseminate your episodes to many
platforms makes it very easy however
there are recurring costs anywhere from
twenty to thirty dollars a month to
enterprise level can be about thirty
five hundred dollars
I don't think it's unreasonable to think
that perhaps yell at some point might
have sort of an enterprise offering that
we could all tap into and I'm hoping
that you know being here today and
talking with all of you from my
non-expert point of view and with all of
you
maybe we can kind of think about who
here is doing what we're doing who's
planning to do what we're doing and
maybe there are some cost savings and
pulling together and appealing to Yale
to do something kind of in a shared way
and coordinating with Yale broadcast and
GTL and and all the other units across
the school so these are just a couple of
platforms that have made my life really
easy this is not an exhaustive list this
is you know this is pretty easily Google
Bowl but I wanted to give you a really
short kind of crib sheet for again if
you wanted to leave here today just
spend the rest of your after the
afternoon in your office and just crank
it out you could do it with these things
right podcaster Apple comm has pretty
much any resource in every resource you
can imagine to know how to launch a
podcast for Apple it will give you the
aspect ratio for the images that you
need for the square of your podcast
image it will give you for the banner ad
as well libsyn is a great podcasting
hosting platform that I mentioned
headliner app will handle audiograms for
you
audacity will edit if you decide you
want to edit yourself I'm not that brave
Zen caster it's great if you just want
to go in your office and capture some
audio with a microphone and we use Rev
quite a bit for transcripts they're
super quick and you know within an hour
- you can have from delivering your file
to them you'll have a transcribed the
file on your desk so
there are I think we looked into it for
Chinese at some point there are a little
more expensive but you can do it yeah so
so again that was my pretty quick and
not so dirty overview of podcasting and
sort of what we've gone through I will
share my I have a budget that I put
together I meant to add to a slide but I
didn't do that
not quite our budget but you can
approximate something yeah again I hope
that anybody so who here is launching a
podcast or has launched a podcast
I'll just offer some information that I
because I am with a revamping media
services like this just does it for free
at the moment so you know services
services because they are gonna start
charging and I was given $200 yes to
produce one episode yeah no so yeah Ryan
McEvoy has his games ryan is super he
does a lot of this across Yale but I
think his frustration and he shares a
frustration sorry if I'm sorry Ryan I
hope I'm not seen and guy we share a
frustration which is there's a lot of
excitement around creating new things
but institutional memory being as it is
sometimes aligns with our one-year
two-year program sometimes those
initiatives fall to the wayside and so
there's a lot of focus energy leading up
and then things get left and so I think
we all want to kind of focus on the
highest return on our investment and
those kind of long lead you know
flagship podcasts so I would say if
you're gonna go to Ryan he's a great
consultant if you're gonna go to some
some of the folks like Froylan crews on
at som I don't know the person at CTL
sit down with them chat with them
they'll tell you everything they're so
open and collaborative they're great but
I would love to stress more the DIY
aspect of some of the tools that are out
there because although they're great and
right now they will do it they will be
charging very soon
and if you're gonna spend yeah we're
just podcasting fit into your overall
media strategy where do you see that in
terms of you know adding value sure and
I will say actually we should think more
about that right Jonathan and Emily I
think it's something that we decided
this would be really like a good test we
think it is a flagship we think it
speaks really well to it tells a
wonderful story that are about our alums
right now and about our students and the
fact that there is this wonderful kind
of collaboration between them and the
sector's they're going into so I think
the hypothesis is it will be a great
flagship for that a great part of our
media but I offerings but I don't know
that we can say necessarily I think
we're still seeing how it fits in with
the overall I think we'll continue to
invest in it in the near term and and in
terms of the percentage of sort of our
offerings it's really minimal I mean
it's a pretty minimal part of it however
it takes a lot of time so budget wise
minimal in terms of time for our our
folks and resources probably a little
bit more than I had expected and
anticipated Laurie
so that's her yes that's a great
question and I'm thinking about that
right now I think the challenge that
Jonathan Emily and I were talking about
is if there was a host who would it be
if it were a student host we lose
students every two years or every year
so there are some fantastic students and
in fact I think it goes without saying
that there's a lot of folks that go into
the making of not just our season but
each episode I'm just one of many people
including students there's one student
who really stepped up and helped me
think through and reach out to other
students so to answer your question I
think I might keep it without a host but
I think there are ways that we can
simplify the production process of it
and I'd also like to find ways to get
more of our faculty involved some of the
practitioners involved in sharing their
career advice again because that's kind
of the theme of it
to your point
it's a lot of work but I for us I think
it's probably a good investment I will
complain a little bit here and there but
at the end of the day I think that's why
we're all here and I think that's what
we're trying to do is to you know
educate for us educating leaders for
business and society and so if that
means doing a lot more prep on the front
end I think that's just gonna happen if
that's going to be how it will be for us
so that's a great question I think we've
had about 2,000 downloads right now
which it's not very big right it's not
big so I would I would like to see that
improve but I think it's important to be
honest about these numbers I really want
to increase our subscribers
unfortunately you know we lose students
right now and over the summer it's
pretty quiet so it's hard for us we've
noticed episode launches you know we
peek with analytics and then it goes
down and then we peek with every episode
released and now that the students are
out the last episode we released after
graduate after commencement was a little
lower than we had expected so I'm still
trying to figure out how to grow that I
do think though that there's a value and
saying that we're doing this
that's som is supporting this and so
maybe not all of it is quantifiable at
the moment and I will also make a note
that so libsyn the publishing platform
has some pretty good okay analytics
they'll show you how many downloads per
episode when however Apple is sort of a
black box and they give you very very
little so it's been really hard to see
what the drop-off rates have been how
many people have actually listened we we
consciously made our episodes only 20 to
30 minutes just try to make again a
hypothesis we just thought that a 45
minute conversation for our listeners
maybe wasn't the way to launch but I
personally listen to hour and a half
long podcasts so
so it's very I feel hope I'm hoping that
the innovations within the podcasting
space and include analytics and some of
them or some of the insights into that
sure so we have an alum in a student and
so I work I usually take the first stab
at the script and then I share it with
the student and then I sit with that
student and I walked them through I
actually have them talk through the
intro and outro with me just so they
feel comfortable with it I have them go
through almost every question I'd say
half of my student half of the students
I've worked with have been very
proactive and have asked a lot of their
own questions I'd say the other half
didn't do that at all just the way it is
and so the prep work the in-person prep
work was really helpful however a lot of
them are not used to being in the studio
and so it took you know we usually allow
for about an hour and a half from start
to finish even though the podcast itself
the final product is only 20 minutes
there's an hour and a half there and so
by the end of the conversation the
student is warmed up and we usually go
back and rerecord the intro outro I see
guy nodding he's yeah people it takes a
while for us to get comfortable on yeah
is that answer your question
so that's a great question so I'll
mention that I don't even know if I
remember exactly but I remember I wanted
to put together a matrix so the first
thing I did was we put together an idea
of the sectors that we wanted to cover
so we wanted to cover for som we wanted
to cover at least in the launch season
we wanted to cover consulting finance
sustainability health care technology
venture capital we knew we wanted to
kind of hit these topics so the
pre-production process took quite a bit
for this exact reason because we were
coming up with this matrix of students
and alum and trying to connect them that
was that was probably the most difficult
part of this whole process and the most
time-consuming for us so after I we came
up with these themes I reached out to
our alumni office and I said can you
give me a list of alums
that you think would be willing to
articulate their experiences within this
they gave me a list then I reached out
to a couple other people both my
colleagues in the office colleagues and
the Entrepreneurship program a couple
students that I knew asking them do you
know any current students do you know
any alums that are in this space so I
created this matrix right students alums
sectors I tried to see where the overlap
was and then I made the asks in some
cases I went to the alums first and said
would you be interested in doing this
and I match them with a student and a
lot of cases I had a student in mind
already because I had one or two
students got me three or four students
so it was kind of a lovely kind of
network effect of finding a couple great
students find those champions within the
student body right so I had a student
government president who was very very
helpful and proactive I had one student
who did the vet who did the most recent
episode Michelle Kwan who is an interest
in venture capital I think she's going
to be more of a producer this coming
year she's really interested in being
more active so it's sort of piecing it
together when you can in the back
plausible deniability can probably
articulate that better than I could
he's been able to help me again I get
this is not a I if I had brought
everybody here who had participated in
this effort they were just you know
probably more more than you sitting
there so my colleague is sort of aware
of what we should and shouldn't do with
the Yael mark the designer that we
worked with us also sort of familiar
with that so we had sort of a a good
good insight but I would say when in
doubt I guess ask John gamble and I
guess if you need to ask general counsel
it's probably the best way to go did we
do that
No
yeah so iTunes U is probably gonna go
away
so if you have a podcast me want it to
be listed within our iTunes U or within
Yale's
brand first of all it's very difficult
to get there these days Yale has made it
I'm sorry Apple has made it very
difficult but that is actually probably
going to be going away but in the near
term if you do want your podcasts or
audio there and you have something in
the Apple Store you can send it to Ryan
McEvoy and he will make it happen
he will also add it to their soundcloud
playlist so that's something else you
shouldn't you should be doing did you
have a question
and the main reason you have a visual
podcast because for what a back full
manuscripts and material that people
need to see Henry's here so have you had
any experience with visual
I'm currently posting which does allow
for more consistent or it could be put
out and it has to do with the actual
faculty working fine he wants item as
well as off-site access service memories
preservation all that so I don't know
anything about visual podcasts in fact
I'm sort of because we don't have this
visual medium I totally get why you need
that right for us it's more ideas based
and so there's not as much visual
accompaniment so in fact I'm it we're
advising one faculty member who has
video recorded all of these interviews
we're just going to also be just
releasing them audio only and stripping
out the video that works for us doesn't
work for you so you have a unique
challenge and podcasting that or making
that audio only or yeah wouldn't
wouldn't really work for you so I would
probably say you have more in common
with my video colleagues so connecting
with John zabrowski and Ben Hecht at som
might be a great you know if you're
looking for colleagues to to collaborate
with or to just you know pick their
brain there it would be a good place to
start
yes they're kind of a kind of their way
for the vast majority of people in the
world you can never have direct access
to you to have it in their heads it's
arm whatever faculty who may be
participating in one of that so my
podcast leader said it's like having her
office hours but you know for everybody
and so people can you know I think that
we do a lot of that on our website and
in our media relations and so forth but
this is just like pure uncut you know I
mean it's pure I mean you know access
and I think we're all everyone in the
university it's the university school I
like that I think that's so perfect and
that resonates we were just leading
obsession with and Fiona said something
so one of our professors unit Scott
Morton was just talking about how you
know in the classroom she could only
reach so many people but when she's on
Twitter she can reach thousands and
being able to open up sort of what has
seemed like a closed box like the Yale
classroom is really important and I
think I hope that that's a hypothesis
that were we're using and why why it's
so important to podcast and to share
these stories between students and alum
because it's not normally something that
it's as if you're sitting in on a
informational interview right that's
that's why we are doing these recordings
and so we're hoping that by doing that
we're demonstrating a lot of what maybe
you can't see it yell som in terms of
content yeah
some paid social but like one other
thing is on my agenda items for the next
couple of weeks is it's basically what
else should we be doing so there's a lot
that one can do to promote I mentioned
creating a news item on putting out
social posts doing some not just kind of
native stuff but inorganic stuff rather
but like you know really doing some paid
social transcripts help with SEO there's
a number of articles recently that I've
talked about the reasoning behind having
your own having a podcasts own website
and Google now has some tags that you
can add to your website that will allow
your podcast to be found within their
Google at their algorithm and what else
I mention my SEO as well so SEO I think
it's really important so no we don't
have a dedicated budget something that I
am thinking about right now after this
first season and looking back at what
worked and what didn't work promotion is
something that we need to focus on
we're next to no money for like $20 so
that's great to know we've noticed
actually we haven't done this quite as
much as I'd like but we've noticed too
we try to include it in some of our
email marketing so prospective students
perspective student emails alumni email
newsletters
I think that's driven a little bit of
traffic so yes yes and yes so we're
really lucky at s2m we've got a
dedicated team downstairs and at the
moment they're willing to work with us
and so I've relied really heavily on
them I have you know we also have I have
two colleagues who are video dedicated
video colleagues who have the equipment
and one of them had had to pinch-hit for
me because I didn't have any studios
available for me which is another reason
why you should DIY because chances are
when your subjects are only are only
available in that one hour interval like
them you can't find a studio so you
should always have that backup space you
should always have your equipment even
if you think you're gonna do it in a
studio so we do have a little bit of
they have equipment my colleagues have
equipment omnidirectional mics which
meant they work out just fine though in
this case and then backups are really
important so he has he had a dedicated
backup recorder you're in a studio they
already have a backup setup so if you're
gonna buy our own equipment microphone
you know backup a backup recording
situation but you could also do that a
lot online and so I just relied on
Doncaster as a backup to I know the
broadcasting Center has an ISDN line
that I have a I have a telephone line
that people can call in we've been using
tape sinks which is basically what that
means is and again I recommend using a
tape sync it basically is somebody who
will go to a spot that's not where
you're at or maybe where you're at and
just record audio side of it and so we
did that all we did that in me in each
case and it's about $150 an hour that's
not a lot of money if you want really
great clean audio yeah so if you have
the budget for it I think doing a tape
sync for any of your off-site stuff is
important yeah all right well I if you
can if you're doing a podcast if you're
launching one if you're thinking about
launching one if you could reach out to
me I'd love to kind of get a group
together across scale and just try to
you know collaborate a little bit more I
think it's something that I know I hear
a lot of a lot of people doing and I'm
learning a lot I know I can learn a lot
from you maybe you can turn me into a
more of an expert and and yeah so thank
you for coming and connect believe so
[Music]